GEMA we're here at the niccola's Oakwell
Couture 2013 autumn winter collection
what you're looking forward to at the
show today I'm looking forward to seeing
what I might like to wear on the red
carpet I think his designs are
incredible creative I'm wearing one of
his at the moment yeah looking
absolutely gorgeous it is your absolute
example of what you can see in the show
today I'm sure thank you okay let's talk
a bit about what's been going on for you
this year we've been enjoying you very
much in dates recently what's it been
like making that yeah it's been a
brilliant experience I think it's very
unusual to have a drama where it's just
a two hander that's character-driven so
it was like doing many plays really and
then filming them and I had I had
wonderful cast mates and great writers
so yeah I'm really pleased for how it's
gone you think we can look forward to
any more dates in the future I hope so I
don't I don't know you never find out
about these things until much later but
I think I think the show's got got legs
and the reception's been really really
warm really lovely I think people have
really responded to it which is great
there's also very warm reception for
fresh meat another show that you were in
as well what was it like making that
what did you enjoy about in particular
uh it was just great fun I mean I got to
play a really fun character that was
very out there and not not very nice
but that's that's very fun to play and
everyone got on and yeah again with that
show we didn't know how it was going to
be received but it's been been great if
you can look forward to any more fresh
meat as well for you for that
I don't know about that that's not to
Sam and Jesse they're creators but
they're filming another season now I
think and it's been talk of a film but
we'll we'll see now I know you've got
lots of stuff coming up among them is
Jack Ryan and movie and also the double
as well tell us a little bit about each
of oh yeah well the double is Richard
Ayoade a who directed me in submarine
it's his new film
and it stars Jesse iceberg I don't know
how much I'm allowed to say actually but
it's very it's funny but it's dark I
hope people really enjoy it's a cracking
script and Jack Ryan I play an American
spy and Kevin Costner stars in it with
Keira Knightley and Chris Pine and
Kenneth Branagh as a director and it's a
kind of a clever thriller I would say I
looking forward to it now what's it like
being directed by both Kenneth Branagh
and I Richard alley as well yeah they're
both incredibly talented and they know
they really know what they want but
they're very good at getting out of
there getting it out of there actors in
a very clever way so you often get the
end of thing oh I see I see that they
wanted me to do what they don't you know
they're not dictatorial with it they're
very clever and and what can we see from
you after there I've been doing quite a
lot of theater so perhaps that's
something that I will be doing more of
in the next year
what kind of theatre would you like to
do next you thing I well I've just done
a comedy drama that's all about identity
and race in America so I see something
completely different actually maybe you
have something that love perhaps yeah
continued in date soon yeah exactly
whichever it's been Alice Lee let me to
speak to you thank you enjoy the show
tonight
yeah thank you tea
you